- Climate is so important that, you know,
I'm dedicated to the cause and
whatever obstacles there are.
I'll keep finding new ways to
try and move this innovation.
It would be tragic to not
have that demonstration money.
Critical for all these
climate technologies
is to get the cost down and
to be able to scale them up
to a pretty gigantic level.
You'll never get that scale up
unless the government's coming
in with the right policies
and for the top areas, the right policy
is exactly what's in
that infrastructure bill.
What's great in this bill is this has
a demonstration funding over 25 billion,
until you do the demonstration project,
you cannot get to a market driven price.
And the goal of the demonstration projects
is to drop the green premium
over time, all the way to zero.
So that using clean hydrogen eventually,
as part of how you make steel for example,
the market alone makes that effective.
And so the government and innovation
play this dramatic role,
not just for the US,
but for the entire world.
- These big leaps forward
to demonstrate that we can actually do it.
So what this shows, this leadership shows
is that the private sector
is hungry to partner,
is hungry to get in the game on this.
And we're hoping that
this example sparks others
to also step up and make sure
that we can get these
demonstration projects
fully funded and in the
ground and going quickly,
it really helps to grease the skids
to make sure it happens quickly,
'cause we are in a moment of urgency.
(gentle music)
- What happens if the
bill doesn't get passed?
There are still questions
about what the house is going to do.
In that case, do you walk away?
- I would be super disappointed
if the bill doesn't pass,
I will continue to share
that with politicians
of both parties, but the focus
for large demonstration projects
will be outside the United States.
Much more in Europe and Asia
than in the United States,
which means you don't
get the direct connection
with the huge innovation
power of the United States.
You don't get that early
lead in these industries,
which often determines where
the long-term job creation is.
I'll keep finding the ways
to draw in the US innovation.